[Musique]
c'était 28 ans ça fait 28 ans que je
travaille dans l'automobile
c'est simple c'est mon premier essai mon
seul employeur en fait c'est pas
vraiment une surprise parce que
l'automobile c'est ma passion depuis je
suis tout petit passion qui prend la
place je suis d'ailleurs quand j'avais 7
ans que j'allais à l'école avec mes
copains de classe notre exercice préféré
c'était de repérer sur le chemin de
l'école les plus belles voitures et une
fois qu'on les avait repérés
c'était ce collé à la vitre et de
regarder le compteur de vitesse alors
celle qu'on préférerait évidemment
c'était les plus belles et qui allait le
plus vite possible et sur cette échelle
là la voiture qui m'a le plus marqué et
beaucoup d'entre vous ici le savent
c'est la citroën sm une voiture avec un
style extraordinaire
forcément et en plus un concentré de
technologie à la fois la suspension de
la ds le confort et la performance avec
un moteur v6 maserati bref là j'étais la
plus confortable de l'époque et c'était
une voiture française un fleuron de
l'industrie française au même titre que
d'autres paquebot france le concorde où
le tgv
et si j'ai choisi de vous parler de
cette voiture
ce soir c'est pas juste que je laime et
c'est aussi et surtout parce que c'est
un exemple de rebond particulièrement
intéressant c'est même un double rebond
un bond en avant et un fort rebond un
bond en avant parce que pour la marque
le cahier des charges s'étaient succédé
à une voiture tout aussi extraordinaire
la ds
quinze ans après il fallait faire encore
mieux
puis un fort rebond parce que après un
succès qui a bien pris après des succès
même aux états unis
vous savez que les succès des voitures
françaises aux états unis sont plutôt
rares eh bien il a fallu arrêter sa
production
quatre ans après quinze mille voitures
produites seulement fort au bond et
pourquoi
et là parce que dans l'intervalle la
première crise pétrolière était passé
par là le coût du baril de pétrole
avaient flambé les taxes sur les grosses
cylindrées avait augmenté la voiture
était sorti du marché lorsque ça
m'inspire c'est que aujourd'hui la
question des taxes la question la rareté
des matières premières se pose de
manière encore plus critique et la
question c'est même plus dure encore que
celle de la rareté du pétrole
c'est celle de l'avenir de la planète et
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
est-ce que l'automobile telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui a encore une place
sur cette planète
on ne nous parle que de voitures
électriques
partagez et autonome
en même temps nos voitures sont
fabriquées dans une usine et l'image de
lusine c'est encore celle des temps
modernes salle dangereuse et c'est la
lutte des classes donc est-ce que l'une
une industrie automobile peut avoir
encore de l'avenir sur notre planète
aujourd'hui est ce que l'industrie
automobile ne va pas être la prochaine
sur la liste de toutes celles qui ont
déjà disparu
les mines la sidérurgie le textile
l'électronique l'informatique est ce que
l'avenir de l'automobile c'est pas tout
simplement dans un musée pourtant
l'automobile la bagnole comme on dit
c'est quelque chose
est ce qu'on peut imaginer james bond
sans cette db5 est ce que le mythe du
james dean aurait été le même sans sa
porsche
et puis l'automobile c'est aussi un
objet d'art
pensez au concours d'élégance c'est une
source d'inspiration pour les artistes
et des tas de chanteurs qui ont choisi
le t mobile g1 en est un
particulièrement en tête freddie mercury
qui chantait i'm in love with my car je
connais personne d'autre pas d'autres
chanteurs qui est chanté à ce point son
amour pour un produit industriel et puis
l'automobile c'est quand même un
milliard aujourd'hui d'objets sur la
planète ce qui prouve bien que c'est
quelque chose d'utile
ce qui prouve bien que ça rend un
service extraordinaire qui est celui de
la liberté de mouvement est d'ailleurs
j'ai envie qu'on se pose une question ce
soir
comment est ce que vous êtes venu au zoo
d'amnéville ce soir
à pied en bicyclette non aux flyers ben
non en transport en commun
c'est compliqué de venir en transports
en commun ici un nom la plupart d'entre
vous est venu tout seul dans une voiture
thermique possiblement avec un moteur
diesel et c'était probablement un suivi
alors et les usines les usines elles
c'est quand même quelque chose aussi les
usines d'abord c'est des milliers
d'emplois est important et ensuite c'est
une vie en communauté
c'est des projets partagés c'est de l'
envie d'aller de l'avant et c'est de la
technologie c'est les perspectives et on
voudrait voir ses usines disparaître
alors justement ça aussi c'est une
histoire de rebond et si je crois au
rebond l'industrie automobile c'est
parce que l'histoire automobile
c'est une histoire de rebond l'histoire
du groupe
elle est faite de rebond je vais pas
reprendre les plus de 100 ans de
l'histoire du groupe
mais juste 4 reperd 4 jalons le premier
1892 les frères peugeot qui faisait des
petites pièces de métal décidé crinoline
des corsets ont décidé de rebondir et de
faire des automobiles 1934 la traction
avant une révolution cette voiture
c'était la première fois qu'au lieu
d'être poussés par le moteur on était
tiré par le moteur les bières qu'est ce
que ça change
mais ça change qui avait plus de
mécanique dans l'habitacle que donc la
voiture pouvait être plus basses plus
aérodynamique qui avait plus de place
dans l'habitacle et ça a été un succès
extraordinaire c'était la voiture de
tous des personnalités les plus nobles
aux plus petits malfrats et en même
temps c'est un vrai rebond intéressant
parce que andré citroën l'a lancé
pour sauver son entreprise a été sur le
point de faire faillite
et figurez-vous qu'en dépit du succès
elle a quand même fait faillite et c'est
michelin qui l'a rachetée et lui n'a pas
vu son succès puisqu'il est
malheureusement décédé quelques temps
plus tard troisième jalon un autre
modèle mythique cette voiture une
bouille sympathique légère performante
bien équipé un bon prix et qui elle
aussi a permis à l'entreprise de
rebondir et d'éviter tout simplement la
faillite dernier jalon on était en 82
maintenant je vous emmène en 2012 2013
là cette fois de nouveaux l'entreprise
le groupe a failli disparaître et ce qui
l'a sauvé puisque je suis encore là
aujourd'hui ce qui l'a sauvé
c'est d'avoir décidé de rebondir d'avoir
décidé de diminuer sa taille d'avoir
décidé de réduire sa gamme d'avoir
décidé d'ouvrir son tour de table à des
partenaires l'état et son partenaire
chinois
la famille c'était une entreprise
familiale et c'est ce rebond qui a
permis au groupe de continuer alors dans
cette grande histoire de l'automobile
il ya aussi la petite histoire des deux
usines que j'ai l'honneur de diriger
trémery et metz des usines qui sont nés
respectivement il ya 40 ans et à 50 ans
de la reconversion du territoire c'était
après les mines c'était après la
sidérurgie trémery a démarré en
fabriquant des moteurs essence et avec
la fameuse crise pétrolière il a fallu
changer passé au diesel et reinerie est
devenue la plus grosse usine de
fabrication diesel au monde et
maintenant c'est évidemment la page de
l'électrique et ses deux usines sont en
train de passer à l'électrique
la première fabrique déjà les premiers
moteurs électriques et la deuxième va
préparer une boîte de vitesse électrique
pour le futur
et pendant toute cette période de temps
c'était la transformation continue
l'adaptation continue le rebond continu
pour rendre ces deux usines plus
automatisée plus robotisée plus
performante et aujourd'hui elle
accueille des briques technologiques de
l' usine du futur
alors la question qui se pose maintenant
qu'on sait qu'on peut rebondir dans
l'industrie c'est celle du futur
rebondir hockey mère-grand dire ou vers
quoi et ça c'est une question
terriblement ouverte
personne n'a la réponse est juste quand
même quelques repères le premier repère
pour moi et j'y crois profondément c'est
effectivement la liberté de mouvement je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse retirer la
liberté de mouvement aux hommes
je pense que c'est un acquis tellement
important que cela se ferait avec de
terribles rupture et moi je n'imagine
pas partir en vacances là où pour m
emmener ma bicyclette c'est à dire
peut-être à 1 100 200 km maximum
non et je m'imagine encore moins dans un
monde virtuel où il suffirait de
chausser des lunettes de réalité
virtuelle pour parcourir le monde des
univers inconnu rencontré des tas de
gens et en même temps vivre dans un
cagibi
comme vous pouvez le voir dans cette
image de ready player one
le dernier film de steven spielberg
alors à partir de là il reste automobile
mais quel type d'automobile bon une
tesla cent mille euros 450 km
d'autonomie faut quelques heures aussi
pour la recharger où sont les bornes de
recharge et si j'en trouve une
est-ce qu'elle va être disponible cette
voiture électrique
il ya des aimants les aimants c'est avec
du cobalt extrait en république
démocratique du congo racines et en
chine où sont fabriqués aussi les
batteries dont l'électricité provient
du charbon de l'autre côté de la
frontière du nucléaire en france
et puis battre est abandonnée il faut
les recycler vous voyez que la question
de l'empreinte co2 de tout ça elle est
encore posé ça va bien alors c'est perdu
et je pense pas je pense que de toute
façon on passera par l'électrique je
vais vous allez nous allons tous un
moment donné rouler en voiture
électrifiée ou électriques
il n'y a pas le choix et pourquoi n'y a
pas le choix parce que la réglementation
européenne aujourd'hui elle nous dit
moins de co2 et c'est certainement très
bien mais en même temps l'opinion
publique nous dit pas de diesel
le diesel c'est mal pourtant c'est très
bien on co2 mais les l'opinion publique
a tué le diesel alors qu'est ce qui
reste
mais il reste que l'électrique donc il
va falloir y passer mais en même temps
l'électrique c'est aussi très bien et
pourquoi pas ce que c'est silencieux
imaginez les villes silencieuse ça ne
pollue évidemment pas là où ça roule
on va respirer ça ne sent rien et puis
c'est en même temps aussi du plaisir de
conduite parce que l'électricité
ça permet aux voitures d'accélérer très
fort et puis toutes les questions qu'on
a posés sur le cobalt les batteries
cetera
aujourd'hui elles sont sur la table et
les entreprises les laboratoires
les universités il travaille pour
trouver des solutions remplacer le
cobalt par le nickel mettre au point
l'hydrogène pour pouvoir l'utiliser
comme réservoir d'énergie ce qui
règlerait le problème de la recharge
aussi et alimenter des piles à
combustible qui elle-même se chargerait
de remonter les batteries donc c'est
possible c'est possible et ça va venir
et comme en plus la voiture de demain
elle sera non seulement électrique mais
elle sera aussi autonome et bien on
pourra en profiter à bord pour vraiment
profiter du voyage rencontrer du monde
puisque ce sera une voiture partagée ou
même regarder sa dernière série
télévisée puisque elle avancera tout
seul et cerise sur le gâteau si on a
envie de reprendre la main eh bien on
pourra la conduire et retrouver ce
plaisir unique de se transporter là où
on a envie de se transporter et c'est
typiquement le cas de cette idée de
jeunes alors voilà l'industrie a su
rebondir
l'industrie est prête à rebondir vers
quelque chose elle sait pas encore
exactement quoi
mais elle a envie de le faire et je
crois que c'est ça le plus important
c'est qu'on a une chance extraordinaire
de pouvoir écrire la nouvelle page de
l'automobile
la nouvelle histoire l'automobile et je
pense que ça n'est qu'une question
d'état d'esprit
le rebond finalement c'est un état
d'esprit c'est une question de bonne
volonté et je crois justement que c'est
cet état d'esprit qu'il y a quelques
années lorsque justement je revenais de
l'école ce fameux chemin qui m'amenait
de l'école primaire à la maison et
réciproquement
c'était un soir de juin
c'était la fin de l'école le cm2 voilà
et penser à quelque chose que mes
parents m'avaient dit mais pistons c'est
sérieux maintenant tu rentres collège
il va falloir arrêter de jouer aux
petites voitures
je peux vous dire que ça m'a traumatisée
et c'est là que j'ai décidé de rebondir
ok j'arrêterai de jouer aux petites
voitures mais au moins jean fabriquerait
plus tard
[Applaudissements]